[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory since
you guys enjoyed the all Hogwarts
subjects video so much we thought we'd
make one for all of the her warts
professors this list will include all
past and present professors that we know
by name obviously if this list were to
cover all professors since Hogwarts
inception in 990 we'd have a much longer
list but realistically we don't have the
named all of them so we'll just run with
what we know we also won't be including
other Hogwarts staff or Headmaster's
unless they taught as well without the
professors of The Wizarding World young
witches and wizards would be entirely
left to their own devices there would be
a lot less order far more stressed out
parents and a lot more homeschooling
Hogwarts gives students a place to be
themselves interact with other children
and truly tune into their magical
abilities and if it wasn't for all of
the professors on this list that would
never be possible so without further ado
here's the list of professors past and
present at Hogwarts number one
Aurora sinistra Aurora Sinestro is the
Astronomy teacher at Hogwarts she's a
British witch that taught students all
about the events of the night sky
filling them in on all info pertaining
to stars constellations moons and
planets her lessons are taught in the
Astronomy tower and she guides her
lessons with the use of telescopes
number two Albus Dumbledore arias you
many know this character already we know
Dumbledore primarily as the headmaster
of Hogwarts before that Dumbledore was
actually a teacher and taught various
subjects at the school he notably taught
Transfiguration as well as defense
against the dark arts number three
Alecto Cara
Alecto Cairo was a pureblood witch and
the muggle studies professor at Hogwarts
during Severus Snape regime as
headmaster she notably put her own twist
on the course and where the course
formerly taught students about how to
integrate with the muggle
Alecto taught her students that muggles
were no better than animals
number four amicus Kara amicus Cairo was
the brother of electical a dark
pureblood wizard who was appointed as
the Defense Against the Dark Arts
professor during severus snape regime as
headmaster similar to Alecto amicus puts
his own spin on the subject and changed
defense against the dark arts into
basically dark arts teaching students
how to effectively practice the
unforgivable curses number five
Alastor Moody / Bharti meais Crouch jr.
technically it was Alastor Moody that
was appointed as Defense Against the
Dark Arts professor however it turned
out that Alistair moody had been
captured and party miss Crouch jr. was
teaching in his place
Alastor Moody is a Scottish pureblood
wizard and famous aura bartimaeus Crouch
is a Death Eater and the son of party
Mia's Crouch
senior who is a Ministry of Magic
official number six
Bathsheba babbling Bathsheba babbling is
a British witch and a professor of
ancient runes in her ancient runes
course she teaches students about rune
ology which involves deciphering and
translating ancient runes symbols and
alphabets number seven professor
bartholomae professor Bartholomew is a
British wizard and former potions master
at Hogwarts he tortured the school for
quite a long time and knew sir nicholas
de Mimzy popping t'en personally number
eight Cuthbert bins cuspid bins was a
British wizard and history of magic
professor at hobbies bins taught at the
school while alive died one day without
noticing and just continued to teach as
a ghost his lessons are some of the most
boring at Hogwarts and the highlight of
his class is when he enters the room
through the chalkboard number nine
charity Burbage
charity Burbage was a british witch who
taught muggle studies at Hogwarts
unlike Alecto Caro Burbage held a belief
that muggles witches and wizards were
cut from the same cloth maybe not so
different for her publications on muggle
and wizard equality she was brutally
tortured and murdered by Voldemort which
is gruesomely depicted in the Deathly
Hallows
number ten Dolores Umbridge there's
basically nothing good about Dolores
Umbridge she's a half but witch who
taught at Hogwarts after she was placed
there by the ministry she talked to
Vince against the dark arts for a brief
stint then became high Inquisitor and
headmaster shortly thereafter number
eleven firenzi not everyone knows about
this one
Firenze he was a center the same center
that saved harrion forbidden forest in
the philosopher's stone
Firenze II was appointed as the
divination professor from 1996 to 1998
replacing Trelawney for a time after she
was sacked by Umbridge number twelve
filius Flitwick filius Flitwick was a
British wizard dueling champion
ravenclaw and charms expert he was the
resident charms master of Hogwarts and
taught students all about how to perform
them he taught many of the characters
that we know and love Lily Evans James
Potter Sirius Black Remus Lupin Snape
and more number 13 Professor Fortinbras
I doubt you know this one Fortinbras was
a British witch and the former charms
master at Hogwarts long preceding
Flitwick she talks around the same time
as Professor bartholomae and also news
and Nicolas to mimsy popping ttan
personally number 14
Gilderoy Lockhart witch Weekly's most
charming smile Award recipient Gilderoy
Lockhart was a half-blood wizard who
authored new books his books explained
in great detail all of the encounters
that he had with many dark magical
creatures Lockhart taught defense
against the dark arts while he was at
the school Gilderoy however was a bit of
a fraud and was definitely not well
suited to the position number 15 Galatea
Mary thought Galatea Mary thought was a
British witch who taught to defense
against the dark arts sometime between
1920 and 1940 Tom Riddle was initially
one of her students and after he
finished his studies he applied for her
position Riddle was of course famously
turned down which resulted in him
forever jinxing the position number 16
Herbert Barry
Herbert Barry was a British wizard
who taught under Armando Dippet he was
the professor of apology and later left
the posting to teach at the Wizarding
Academy of Dramatic Arts waza number 17
Horace Slughorn Horace Slughorn is a
British wizard with a long history at
the school he was head of Slytherin
house and also served as potions master
Slughorn infamously told Tom Riddle
about Horcruxes Slughorn's fear of
Dumbledore finding out led to his
initial retirement from the posting
Slughorn later returned to the school
after a 15-year hiatus number 18 Minerva
McGonagall Minerva McGonagall was a
Scottish half but which the taught at
Hogwarts school for many years she first
attended the school as a Gryffindor and
later assumed the role of
Transfiguration professor while at
Hogwarts she was also head of Gryffindor
House deputy headmistress and eventually
headmistress number 19 Neville
Longbottom R Neville
we know Neville as the clumsy awkward
boy that started Hogwarts at the same
time as Harry Ron and Hermione after the
second Wizarding war Neville pursued his
passion in herbology and later assumed
the role a professor of theology at
Hogwarts relieving Pomona sprout number
20 Pomona sprout Pomona sprout was a
British witch that taught at Hogwarts
for many years she was the head of
Hufflepuff house and the head of the
herbology department she famously
teaches Harriet bran mining and others
about Mandrake's in the film sprout was
later succeeded by her former student
Neville Longbottom as herbology
professor number 21 queerness quarrel
aah
sniveling spineless Quirrell Quirrell
was a half-blood wizard and former
attendee of hogwarts he was initially
the muggle studies professor but later
assumed the role as defence against the
dark arts professor Voldemort possessed
squirrel during the time he taught
defense against the dark arts
number 22 Remus Lupin Remus Lupin was a
half-blood wizard former Hogwarts
attendee and werewolf he taught defense
against the dark arts at the school
Remus taught his class about all sorts
of nocturnal
beasts including wind ELO's kappas
vampires werewolves pinky punks and more
number 23 rollin de hooch rollin de
hooch was a British witch who worked as
the flying instructor at Hogwarts school
is she full-on professor I'm not sure
but she did teach students and I think
that her posting is important enough for
her to earn a spot on this list number
Rubeus Hagrid Hagrid is a half giant
half a wizard that attended the school
in his younger years Hagrid notably
attended Hogwarts at the same time as
Tom Riddle while hacker's was primarily
the keeper of keys and grounds of the
school he did end up teaching and became
the professor for the care of magical
creatures in his first lesson he taught
the students all about Hippocrates
number 25 Sylvanas
kettle burn Sylvanas kettle burn was a
British wizard who liked Hagrid served
as professor for the care of magical
creatures kettle burn was a little bit
reckless which did not mesh well with
his posting kettle burn would eventually
lose an arm and one and a half legs
number 26 Severus Snape Severus Snape
was a half but wizard who taught
multiple subjects at Hogwarts he started
off as potions master where he talked
for 15 years then assumed the role of
professor for defense against the dark
arts he would also later become
headmaster of the school Snape is such a
dynamic character throughout the films
and one of my favorites number
twenty-seven Sybill Trelawney Sybill
Trelawney was a British half but which
came from a long line of celebrated
seers she famously told the prophecy
concerning Voldemort and the one with
the power to vanquish him this prophecy
of course leading to the murder of the
Potters Trelawney taught divination at
Hogwarts have quite a long time though
there was a short hiatus when she was
dismissed by Umbridge number 28
septum--ah vector professor septima
vector taught arithmetic at the school
and though it is unconfirmed she likely
taught the advanced version of the class
as well she was a British which they
liked to give lots of complicated
homework which was a veritable treat for
the studious Hermione
she taught in classroom 7a she was known
to be very strict and old-fashioned
number 29 professor swoops takes
professor swoop strikes was the potions
master at Hogwarts as some unconformity
point in history a portrait of swoops
takes is hung in the tracery Hall at
Hogwarts swoops dykes was an
entomologist and held extensive
knowledge of magical insects number 30
Wilhelmina grub Lea plank Wilhelmina
grub Lee plank was a British witch and
substitute teacher for the care of
magical creatures
at Hogwarts she mainly just took over
for Hagrid when he was unable to teach
she was a very competent teacher that
was said to be very kind-hearted and
caring she was an expert in majnu ology
and though no one ever said many felt
that she was the best professor than
Hagrid in the subject
despite his seniority though we don't
know their names
there would also have been professors
throughout history that taught advanced
arithmetic magical art ghoul studies
magical music alchemy and more and that
concludes the list of all the
professor's past and present that taught
at Hogwarts at least the ones that we
actually know about as the school was
founded in 90 I'm sure there would have
been hundreds of professors throughout
the ages I wonder how the subject
evolved over the course of the school's
history
and that's it for this video if you
enjoyed it please hit the like button
did we miss any professors we might have
so if we did please let us know down in
the comment section below until next
time you are Harry
you